Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show, so
former Trump strategist Steve Bannon,
when he's not fighting off criminal charges
for a build the wall money laundering scheme
or fighting off charges for contempt of Congress
having to do with the January 6th Capitol riots.
He hosts a TV and radio show on Real America's
voice called the War Room, wherein he tries to
build up an audience of Trump supporters. And his
thing is to really appeal to the gung ho ones,
the ones who believe that Trump is the savior. And
Trump really won the 2020 election, but if he was,
of course, robbed by Joe Biden and the Democrats
and voter fraud and all of this nonsense, now,
I think that Steve Bannon is an obvious grifter.
He pretends to be one of these anti-establishment,
anti-elitist folks when at the same time, he has
degrees from Georgetown and Harvard, and he used
to work at Goldman Sachs and in Hollywood. But
his thing is to scam diehard Trump supporters into
thinking that he's one of them, right? He's a true
working class American kind of guy. And sometimes
he quite literally scams people. If you look at
that money laundering scheme that he allegedly
did. Well, Bannon is always trying to build up
some media attention, always trying to make a
headline and some recognition for himself. And
he's done it yet again, this time by supporting
Fox host Jesse Watters in his time of need. Now,
Walters, as we talked about on the show this week,
he went to a USA conference called America Fest,
and Waters used the strong rhetoric against Dr.
Anthony Fauci, implying without directly saying
that people should hunts down Fauci and kill
him. Water said stuff like Boom, he is dead.
Ambush and kill shot. Now, Waters was speaking
metaphorically, of course, but it's clear what he
was doing. And it's incredibly irresponsible given
the fact that Fauci and his family have received
a tremendous amount of death threats over the past
couple of years, mainly from Trump supporters.
And he's obviously worried for his safety,
is worried about some crazy Trump supporter
attacking him. So Waters words definitely add
some fuel to the fire there. And Fauci followed
up by saying that Fox should fire Jesse Waters for
his comments. But of course, Fox News is not going
to do that. They're going to stick by their guy
there and talked about this story earlier this
week, if you want to check that clip out. But now
Steve Bannon is getting in on the fun he is
piling on, and he can see that Jesse Waters got
some attention from all this, and now Bannon wants
to share in some of that spotlight. I'd imagine
that Bannon no longer wants to be relegated to
the likes of Real America's Voice, and he wants
to be now a Fox News host, or he wants some sort
of prime time radio job or something like that. So
let's take a look at what Steve Bannon had to
say his his perspective on this controversy.
And then we'll follow up on the other end.
Speaker 5: Look at Jesse Waters great Jesse Waters
there. Tell exactly what you doing to force-feed
Mr. Ricks. I've only told anybody it's about you
funding the Chinese Communist Party play lab.
You liar. You're going to be held accountable
and your buddy, your partner. Collins with it.
Kahlon's Collins can run away. He's leaving.
We're getting him and we're getting you. You're
going to be held accountable and responsible for
what you've done. Tony Short Commercial Break
We back with Darren Beattie, Ben Hartwell.
Speaker 1: So he says that Jesse Watters is a
great guy, and he says that we're getting you
having to do with Anthony Fauci. All of this
aggressive stuff with the religious Christmas
music going on in the background, that really
was quite the contrast there, I have to say.
And obviously, these threats don't amount
to what you would need for criminal charges
or anything like that, nor should they.
This definitely falls under free speech
because they are veiled threats, after all,
but you always have to be on the lookout for
a stochastic terrorism event. There is a real
possibility that someone in waters audience or
Bannon's audience, they could hear these words.
The ambush comment kill shot, we're getting you,
et cetera, and decide that these are calls to
action, and they could decide to take action
into their own hands and carry out something
really egregious against Anthony Fauci over them.
And we've seen it happen before with different
people. We've seen it with members of Glenn Beck's
audience. We've seen it with Bill O'Reilly's
audience. If you have an audience of thousands
of people or millions of people and they watch
you every day and they believe what you say,
there's a chance that maybe just one person
can really take those words to heart.
And maybe they're not the most mentally
stable, and they decide that they're going to
view it as a call to action and they could go out
and kill someone because of the words that you
said there. And so you have a responsibility
to your audience and society more broadly
not to be doing that stuff and not to be speaking
so recklessly. And just the final point, because
Bannon is now making a career off of sucking up to
Donald Trump, acting like this big pro-Trump guy
and, you know, trying to appeal to his supporters.
Did everyone forget that Donald Trump turned on
this guy a while ago? Like, not only did Trump
fire Steve Bannon after the Charlottesville
incident for being toxic. He also released the
following statement about him after it came out
that Michael Wolff used Steve Bannon as a source
for the book Fire and Fury. Quote Michael Wolff is
a total loser who made up stories in order to sell
this really boring and untruthful book. He used
sloppy Steve Bannon, who cried when he got fired.
And begged for his job now, sloppy Steve has been
dumped like a dog by almost everyone. Too bad.
So this is Steve Bannon's life now. I guess he
has to make a living off of sucking up to Trump,
who fired him and publicly ridiculed him. He has
to try to appeal to the lowest common denominator
of Trump supporters and reassure them all of their
worldview. It's pathetic stuff, but
that's exactly who Steve Bannon is.